Chris?
Charlie?
- Who was it !? - Who who ?
A man...
a bearded man ...
was right there ...
to stare at me ...
before disappearing ...
What!
Oh yes. It's Khyan.
The new roommate.
- You're kidding ?!
We kept the last room
for my collection of unicycles!
Add a bit of your collection
before thinking about firing people.
Well...
B'oui ... Okay. It's okay with me.
Sorry to get carried away.
Well.
Just give him a chance, okay?
In addition, he prepares us tea!
- Charlie: 1 sugar -
- Granulated sugar -
You were saying ?
The tea is ready.
- That's nice ... - Call me Khyan!
It's cool to know you ...
- Is tea to your liking?
I imagine... ?
All the better.
I have prepared another for you.
Charlie?
Yes... ?
Everything is fine !?
I believe...
Thanks for the tea ...
Did you taste it?
Is it tasty?
Delicious !
I do not bother you, I hope.
- Oh, no, no! Not at all ! - Yes...
Naturally...
Well, I'm going to withdraw.
Sleep well.
You do not have to drink this thing!
He did it for me ...
You force yourself! It is obvious...
I made you a little tea this morning.
I know how important he is to you ...
Tchin!
Both are for me ?!
Both !?
Charlie?
What...
It's not right?
- Everything is fine !
Oh, no, I could never ...
Well, if you insist ...!
He knows we're here?
- Yeah ... - Nan ...
He's a little stressed, that's all.
A cup of tea would do him good!
I'm not sure that ...
I'll make him tea ...!
We made you some tea, Charlie.
We know how much you love tea.
There, sweet ...
Drink this tea, everything will return to order.
- Charlie?
Are you OK ?
Do you want a little more tea?
- It's a crisis!
- Your tea kills him!
- Tea is good for you!
- Everyone loves tea!
- It's not tea!
- It's sugar!
I do not want to cannose!
- Charlie?
Charlie!
You scared me !
You!
You are a shabby tea maker!
You are aware ?
I never...
- since I was born -
tasted something too ...
heartbreaking!
You would even spoil tea powder!
- It was sugar, Charlie!
- Sugar ! Let's talk about it !
He was not even dissolved properly!
It was like sand in the bottom of my cup!
And you have a problem with milk!
You empty the whole bottle
when a cloud is enough!
You put the milk first, I'm sure!
You are only a monster!
It was so diluted!
- You served me the deca
it's not possible otherwise!
Hey !
It's not...
only a cup of tea ...!
Not when I have to drink
these things one after the other!
- You could say no!
Nobody forced you to drink!
Well...
This is inappropriate !
That's all !
- Guys !
- This sugar is perfect!
- I am sorry...
I got a little carried away ...
All that...
- I do not know what took me!
I'm not mad at you !
I almost killed you, so ...
let's say I did not make a good impression!
- Can I redeem myself?
- Make yourself a real cup of tea ...
No !
- Finally...
- No...
Really, it'll be fine!
But...
I'm sure you're doing really good ...
Scones, and everything ...
That's right, I make excellent scones ...!
Scones...
Scones !
- Scones...
And that thing you do ...
to appear everywhere ...
like: in my room, while I sleep ...
- You do not have to ! Really.
Promised.
- Tadaaa!
My favorite roommate!
Need me ? - Well...
If you do not want me too much ...
I have a surprise for you !
I made tea!
Nah, it'll be fine! But...
- Thank you !